in this video I want to answer the
question is red-meat actually good for
you or bad for you
now if you watch the news where you read
the news or you're on the internet
you're gonna hear that it is very bad
for you it's gonna cause cancer it's
gonna cause diabetes it's going to give
you a heart attack
okay because there's studies that show
that right well the next time someone
tells you that or you hear that or you
see that in some article follow up and
ask either ask the person what was the
study you're referring to or even if
they actually do a an article pull the
string and actually read the actual
study because what you're gonna find out
it will be something called an
observational study
okay that's based on a question here so
it's like asking a large group of people
over the last five years what they ate
and first of all how do you know if it's
the red meat that's causing the cancer
and not all the other foods that they're
eating okay so it's actually ridiculous
it's not even a good study to do to
prove anything okay and also they will
never do Studies on grass fed red meat
okay or organic red meat it's always
going to be probably on some processed
meat and they're not going to
differentiate this because if they did
they would find that consuming organic
grass fed red meat does not cause cancer
diabetes or heart problems so they won't
do that study so the truth is that
studies don't show this link okay now it
is true that there are certain toxins or
toxicity when you overly cook red meat
or other meat okay but if you don't
overly cook your meat and you don't
deep-fry it and you're doing it medium
rare or rare you're going to be in much
better shape also if you add mustard to
that hamburger or meat or garlic or
rosemary or pepper basil oregano and
other herbs you're going to greatly
minimize that toxic effect okay that
being said I want to switch over to
another situation in which read me
would be a problem and that is this if
you if you have too much iron okay too
much iron is very very toxic to your
body so I would highly recommend the
next time you're at your doctor's office
have them test iron because if it's too
high it can be very dangerous also if
it's too low it's very very dangerous
because iron is a strong oxidant so it
oxidate things that kind of rust things
out it can affect the the heart it can
affect the brain it can affect the liver
and cause cirrhosis it can even cause
cancer now the problem with iron is your
body has a real hard time getting rid of
iron now if you're a woman and you're
menstruating you're going to be able to
get rid of it every month but if you're
a guy or you're postmenopausal you're
gonna tend to hold on to that iron and
it could be a problem now there are
certain genetic problems that even make
it worse like this one
hemochromatosis beta thalassemia and
sickle-cell in which case donating blood
might be a really good idea because you
can actually get rid of the excess iron
are you gonna feel a lot better now I
put a link down below of a video that I
did to show the symptoms of iron
overload and what you should do but one
of the remedies would be EDTA this is
the key later and this can pull out iron
it'll pull out other minerals but you
can put other minerals back in just
don't put back in the iron you may also
want to modify what you cook your food
in like if it's a iron skillet for
example you might want to replace that
also check your supplements I do not
recommend consuming supplements with
added iron because you don't need to do
that if you want to get your iron in
your deficient a little bit of red meat
would be fine or actually liver will be
fine but in the supplements they're
usually giving you the wrong type and it
can be a bit toxic over time also if you
drink a lot of alcohol or you're an
alcoholic that can exaggerate this
problem even worse or
if your food is fortified now if you're
doing the ketogenic diet you're not
doing grains so you don't worry about it
but if you're new to my channel and
you're consuming breads and pasta and
grains and you live in the US or Canada
or the UK those are fortified with iron
and that's pretty toxic anyway I just
wanted to create a video on red meat
because it's not a simple answer there's
a couple parts to it so step one don't
overly cook your meat step two do
grass-fed organic just ignore these
studies if you're doing this right here
because they're not real studies and the
next time you're at your doctor's office
just make sure that you get your iron
check just to make sure it's not too
high alright thanks for watching if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos